neil degrasse tyson you probably know
him he has become sort of America's
scientist he's doing cosmos on Fox right
now which is really really fantastic if
you're not watching you should be
watching it uh so he brought up on his
radio show on Startalk radio
that basically we shouldn't be giving
equal time to climate change deniers as
we're giving to actual scientists who
believe in climate change he was talking
to CNN's Miles O'Brien let's take a
listen accuracy in journalism that leads
to what's that what's this phrase is it
fair and balanced I had to ask Myles
what's this fair and balanced movement
that we've been hearing about let's
check it out some stories have one side
that is represented by say 95% of the
scientific community of the world is it
fair in a story about climate change
which I'm obviously talking about to do
this classic journalistic convention of
equal time for both sides this is a huge
mistake I think for journalist I get 95%
and then there's the 5% you get a person
from that 5% right I'll get 50% of your
time is that serving the truth I would
submit to you not as matter of fact that
is feeding obfuscation that is actually
perpetuating a myth dare I say a lie all
right I am completely with you Miles
O'Brien here's the thing if you watch
cosmos every animated section of cosmos
ISM and I'm not saying that any of these
people are right if every animated
section is about how this guy said
something that no one believed and no
one would listen to him and had they not
listened to that ad they you know
continued not to listen to this 1% then
we would never have gravity or whatever
the hell so there's something
fundamentally wrong about the logic here
yes I get that like you're using their
own argument against them climbing the
knife there's there's a better argument
against letting idiots speak yeah you
know then then this one this the logic
here doesn't doesn't play out because
like every scientific idea that has ever
been adopted on the large scale started
with a small scale so you can't go with
the 95 to 5 aspect of it you know a
hundred percent of people thought the
world was flat until they proved it
so that's that's just a logical thing I
think deGrasse Tyson given also if you
watch this show
the cosmos you had that thing like some
people have been picked on all their
lives and when they get to be cool they
just are cool Neil deGrasse Tyson still
is pissed at people like he is now like
meeting out his vengeance on folks and
he gets like he takes like way too long
on the cosmos to talk about these idiot
climate deniers like all right you do
agree with you there is like a 5% like
rubbing in their nose kind of thing I
actually I don't mind it um what do you
think should when when we talk about
climate change or what CNN and all the
networks basically do all them is they
give 50 50 no matter what is based in
science if 97% of the scientists agree
seems like the other guy shouldn't get
50% um yeah I mean fair and balanced
journalism and but are we talking like
does that mean that Fox just doesn't
exist as a news reporting channel like
because I feel like it I do they provide
a 50/50 fair and balance I'm sure
they're not giving 50 percent right to
verify the numbers but I doubt they're
giving 50 percent to the climate change
I mean no I mean I I mean in general
journalism if he's talking about
journalism is supposed to be based on
you know an equal time and perspective
of viewpoints or accuracy at all I just
don't feel as though you know facts
shouldn't even be existing in this world
if that's the case but it's and actually
speaking of facts they actually just it
the fact that they just came out and
said actually said that climate change
is real that should a hundred percent go
go take that last three percent and just
prove that uh the Antarctic is currently
melting into ourselves like right now
there's a piece of the Antarctic that's
like what do they say it's like 20 times
the size of Manhattan right just fell
off and it's melting there's nothing we
can do Miami's gonna disappear so how do
we honestly have a debate about is there
any debate is there any purpose of
having a debate I think I agree that the
proportion of time spent talking like of
people who know what they're talking
about and people who don't know what
they're talking about
I get that the proportion is off and
they should adjust who is allowed to
speak for how long but I think we need
to go the other way of what Neil
deGrasse Tyson is saying I think we need
to let the idiots speak longer
because that's the most entertaining
thing for me it give them 95% of the
time because it's entertaining because
it's so stupid
and then you let's an idiot talk for
long enough and they'll put their foot
in their mouth and no expose how stupid
so that's sort of the theory that you
know Bill Nye the Science Guy did the
debate with the guy from the creation
thing and he believed that Jesus was
riding a dinosaur basically and a lot of
people that's what they were saying well
he just let him hang himself
so that's your like John Oliver did that
thing where he let he brought on 97
scientists that's a debate against three
non-weird weirdo jesus' should we have a
scientist be president we were just
talking about we could maybe have a gay
president do you think maybe it's time
that we have a scientist a scientist not
with that that's a very nature yeah no
really good you ready like a scientist
president like someone who's actually
based in fact and not in the rest of
this money or emotion yeah um I think
that that would be a great idea I'm
going to take the next couple months to
go get my doctorate I'll be back hi Ron
do you want to tell the camera again
like you did the last one I will be
studying very hard for the next four
months don't worry I'll be back to be to
be your first scientific lesbian
president